ce qu'on a moins avant après mois il
paraît que lyon en redditionnelle alors
les régies alors la régie est ce qu'on a
appris à walla autre chose à votre choix
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cameron était celle d'avant celle dabo
est folle non mais c'est d'un
déguisement
je suis vraiment bien comme un sketch
ont marqué la vie de ma mère ce n'est
pas ce qu'était j'avais roulé en cuir
rouge
j'étais vraiment à billets comme assez
vous cherchez à vous de voir
je cherchais quoi vous allez faire
gentiment des courses de coupe du monde
mais je sais que vous avez plein de
modèles différents
ouais mais là en l'occurrence c'était si
le modèle est là là là je vous dis en
vérité je t'ai une période où j'avais
j'avais très peu de sous batterie donc
je m'habille et beaucoup dans des fripes
bouchonniers s'échiner exactement dont
des passings
je suis dégueulasse merci merci c'est
bon alors merci pour la merci de la
production